puede enseñarle a la medicina humana,
y es que si uno lleva su perro, que, digamos,
se persigue la cola compulsivamente, al veterinario del comportamiento,
su primera acción no es prescribir un medicamento;
pregunta sobre la vida del perro.
Quiere saber cuán a menudo el perro sale.
Quiere saber cuánto ejercicio hace.
Quiere saber cuánta vida social tiene con otros perros y humanos.
Quiere hablar con uno sobre qué terapias, en gran parte terapias de comportamiento,
uno ha probado con ese animal.
Esas son las cosas que a menudo suelen ayudar más,
sobre todo si se combina con psicofármacos.
Sin embargo, creo que lo que más ayuda, en particular a los animales sociales,
es el tiempo que pasan con otros animales sociales.
En muchos sentidos, creo que me convertí en animal de servicio de mi propio perro
y he visto loros que lo hacen por personas y personas que lo hacen por loros,
y perros que lo hacen por elefantes y elefantes por otros elefantes.
No sé Uds., pero yo recibo muchos reenvíos de correos
de amistades animales inverosímiles.
Creo que mucho viene de Facebook, el mono que adopta el gato,
o el gran danés que adoptó al cervatillo huérfano,
o la vaca que hace amistad con el cerdo.
Si me hubieran preguntado hace 8 o 9 años sobre esto,
les habría dicho que eran sentimentales sin remedio
y quizá que estaban antropomorfizando mal e incluso que eran montajes,
y ahora puedo decirles que hay algo de realidad en esto.
Es de fiar.
De hecho, algunos estudios interesantes han señalado que los niveles de oxitocina,
la hormona de la unión que liberamos cuando tenemos sexo o amamantamos
o estamos cerca de alguien por el que nos preocupamos mucho,
se elevan en humanos y perros que cuidan unos de otros
o que disfrutan la compañía el uno del otro,
y más allá de eso, otros estudios muestran que la oxitocina se eleva incluso
en otros parejas de animales, en cabras y perros amigos
que jugaban entre sí, por ejemplo, sus niveles luego se dispararon.
Tengo un amigo que me enseñó que la salud mental es bidireccional.
Su nombre es Lonnie Hodge, y es veterano de Vietnam.
Cuando regresó, empezó a trabajar con sobrevivientes de genocidio
y con mucha gente que había pasado por traumas de guerra.
Tenía TEPT y también miedo a las alturas porque en Vietnam hacía rappel hacia atrás
desde los patines de los helicópteros, y le dieron un perro de servicio
llamado Gander, un labrador, para ayudarle a superar el TEPT
y el miedo a las alturas.
Aquí están el primer día que se conocieron,
algo asombroso y, desde entonces han pasado mucho tiempo juntos
visitando a otros veteranos que sufren problemas similares.
Lo que me resulta muy interesante de la relación de Lonnie y Gander
es que unos meses después, Gander desarrolló un miedo a las alturas,
probablemente por mirar a Lonnie de cerca.
Lo genial es que sigue siendo un perro de servicio fantástico
porque ahora, cuando están a gran altura, Lonnie se preocupa tanto
por el bienestar de Gander que olvida su miedo a las alturas.
Haber pasado mucho tiempo con estas historias, hurgando en archivos,
—literalmente, pasé años investigando— me ha cambiado.
Ya no miro a los animales como especie.
Los miro como individuos, y pienso en ellos como criaturas
con sus propios sistemas meteorológicos individuales,
que guían su comportamiento y les informan cómo actuar ante el mundo.
Y realmente creo que esto me ha hecho una persona más curiosa
y con más empatía tanto por los animales que comparten mi cama
y que ocasionalmente terminan en mi plato,
como por las personas que conozco que sufren de ansiedad,
fobias y todo tipo de cosas, y realmente creo
que aunque uno no sepa exactamente qué ocurre en la mente de un cerdo
o de tu pug o de tu pareja, eso no debería impedirnos
sentir empatía por ellos.
Lo mejor que podemos hacer por nuestros seres queridos
quizá sea antropomorfizarlos.
El padre de Charles Darwin le dijo una vez
que todo el mundo podría perder la razón en algún momento.
Por suerte, a menudo podemos recuperarla nuevamente,
pero solo con la ayuda del otro.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)